l'europe de demain a donc commencé
aujourd'hui à maastricht aux pays bas
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
planche vous le savez sur un traité qui
devrait donner naissance à l'union
européenne un pavé de quelques 320 pages
négocié pendant plus de 30 heures où je
m'interdis rien je dis seulement il faut
ratifié je pense que françois mitterrand
lui sentais que c'était une grosse
affaire
c'est un moment tournant dans l'histoire
on franchissait un pas historique
c'était un choix majeur l'abandon de la
souveraineté monétaire des sondages
laissaient entendre que le oui
l'emporterait là
la parole est à monsieur philippe séguin
nous devons dire que nous n'en voulons
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1992 boum c'est la première facture
comme la plus importante
rien ne saura trop bas
écoutez monsieur le président que si je
continue comme ça on va perdre s'il ya
un non au référendum en france bon bah
c'est terminé
la passion des français votre passion
démenti cinglant pour tout ceux qui
prétendaient que l'europe c'est bien
ennuyeux et maastricht bien qu'on
couture
[Musique]
voici la chronique d'une campagne
palpitante d'un tournant politique
majeur
le traité de maastricht instaure l'union
européenne et prévoit la création d'une
monnaie unique
de cette signature par les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement en février 1992
jusqu'à sa ratification par le peuple
français en septembre de la même année
sept mois s'écoulent
sept mois déterminant pour l'histoire de
france et de l'europe
c'était la première fois que les
français réfléchit c'est vraiment sur
l'europe sur le lien entre la france et
sur l'europe et ce qu'ils voulaient
faire
de l'une comme de l'autre
tout le monde en parlait tout le monde
avait une opinion ce geste
extraordinaire d'ailleurs on aurait pu
déplorer que tout le monde s'en fiche ça
aussi transformé le paysage politique
car au clivage gauche droite
traditionnelle se superposer un clivage
mode et unique ou maintien du franc et
plus largement
poursuite de de l'approfondissement
européen ou au contraire retour à une
europe des nations aux
censeurs le plus strict moi j'avais des
passionnément au côté du président
mitterrand j'écris toutes sortes de
textes on m'a jeté à la figure ensuite
en 2005
bon mais moi je préfère être un homme
politique capable de changer d'avis
devant les faits qu'une sorte d'idée au
log illuminés qui quoi qu'il arrive ne
change pas de la campagne chamboule
durablement le paysage politique en
france pendant que le monde et tout
particulièrement l'europe sont en train
de changer
[Musique]
chacun leur tour ils prennent la pioche
casse un morceau du mur qu'ils gardent
dans leur poche ans hugo
le cadenas est cassé et les portes
s'ouvrent vers 23 heures la nuit
dernière des milliers d'allemands de
l'est vous forcer les frontières qui
séparent et l'est et l'ouest il faut se
mettre dans le contexte du moment
c'était la fin la guerre froide c'était
la chute du mur de berlin la
réunification allemande enfin c'était un
contexte international qui était très
particulier
l'urss et le bloc de l'est s'effondre
l'europe change de visage
la chute du communisme mais aussi la
libéralisation des pays
de l'est va coïncider avec cette
libéralisation généralisée c'est un
moment tournant dans l'histoire
et dans ces temps incertains l'esquissé
d'un grand projet sur le point de
s'accomplir un projet dont les contours
se dessinent dans les années 80 celui
d'une nouvelle monnaie en europe
en 88 mitterrand est réélu président de
la république et il avait fait sa
campagne sur l'europe sur l'ouverture
sur bon j'étais à la fois conseillère
mitterrand et je dirigeais le service
européen et donc trop verts entretien
après sa réélection avec le chancelier
kohl en tout petit comité à evian le 3
juin 1988 cadre enchanteur
de l'hôtel royal vue sur le lac la
mitterrandie à col je vais accepter la
libération des mouvements de capitaux
n'était pas encore faire mais à
condition qu'on fasse la monnaie unique
cole regarde l'iran les yeux dans les
yeux et lui dit françois d'accord on va
faire ça
à l'époque le futur euro prévoit de
rappeler les culs
tout ce que vous avez toujours voulu
savoir sur les puces sans jamais oser le
demander pour tous les achats les
paiements les transactions le franc
français n'aura plus cours pas plus que
le mark la lyre ou le flanc à toutes les
devises seront remplacés par des pièces
des billets ou des chèques en écu devenu
la monnaie européenne dans les 12 pays
de la communauté
le 7 février 1992 l'acte de naissance de
la monnaie unique est officiellement
signé dans un traité par les douze pays
de la communauté économique européenne à
maastricht une petite ville des pays-bas
moi j'étais présente c'est un mot
membres enfin pour pour moi très
émouvant parce que j'étais devenue une
idée affaires européennes entre temps
parce que tu es une consécration mon
travail à l'elysée j'en étais très
heureux évidemment il me semble et
c'était un sentiment partagé par tout
ceux qui avaient participé à chaque on
avait quand même on franchissait un pas
historique
il faut se souvenir aussi que les
allemands étaient très attachés aux
marques et que c'était pas toujours
facile pour convaincre les allemands
parallèlement la réunification allemande
les allemands acceptent de renoncer aux
marques pour accepter une monnaie unique
c'est un choix terrible pour l'allemagne
un terrible parce que toute la
reconstruction de l'allemagne d'abord
allemagne de l'ouest puis allemagne
réunifiée s'est faite autour du marquent
leur fierté nationale était là
une bande centrale européenne est créé
les banques centrales nationales ne
devait pas disparaître mais devait se
fondre dans ce qu'allait devenir la
banque centrale européenne le système
européen
mais streetg renforce aussi les pouvoirs
de la commission et du parlement
européen
est consac dans le droit européen la
libre circulation des capitaux
l'idée de la monnaie unique était
intéressant est encore plus intéressant
était la libre circulation des citoyens
et des marchandises à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne alors tout ça
nécessitait des dispositifs très
particulier par exemple pour la médaille
européenne et chalets une banque
centrale et fallait des politiques
communes mais il ya eu des décisions qui
ont été prises qui étaient très précises
désormais signé par 12 pays le traité
doit maintenant pour être appliquées
être ratifiés par les parlements ou par
les peuples au moyen d'un référendum au
départ françois mitterrand ne semble pas
décidé à consulter directement les
français
n'êtes pas tout à fait hostile à un
référendum vous l'écarté pas
définitivement je ne m'interdis rien je
dis seulement il faut ratifié je
souhaite que les assemblées facilite le
travail de la france si c'est
parlementaires sont en mesure de réunir
une majorité des trois cinquièmes c'est
encore une obligation constitutionnelle
sur les textes de la révision je vois
pas pourquoi j'irais compliquer les
choses avec un référendum
mais les divisions ne vont pas tarder à
émerger la gauche pourtant ou pouvoir se
fracture
[Musique]
en avril 1992 pierre bérégovoy remplace
edith cresson à matignon et dès le
lendemain un ancien ministre socialiste
coutumier des démissions fracassantes se
dresse contre françois mitterrand et le
parti socialiste fausse note du côté
socialiste depuis la nomination du
gouvernement celle de jean pierre
chevènement il a dit hier soir qu'ils ne
voteraient pas le traité de maastricht
nous soutiendrons ce gouvernement autant
qu'il nous le permettra et mais attendu
sauf cas de conscience ce qui m'amène à
aborder le sujet de la ratification des
accords de maastricht où je m'apprêtais
plutôt à m'abstenir
je vais un contentieux assez lourd avec
le parti socialiste depuis le tournant
dit de la rigueur qui en fait était un
tournant libéral
1983 et je me battais à l'intérieur pour
infléchir
mais c'est quand j'ai eu lui le traité
de maëstricht qui était vraiment la doxa
libérale qui était le bréviaire de
l'ordo libéralisme allemand pas de
déficit budgétaire lutte prioritaire
contre l'inflation
équilibre équilibre équilibre et
freinage de la croissance donc
augmentation du chômage de masse ils
sévissent est déjà dans notre pays
depuis plusieurs années c'est à ce
moment là que je me suis dit il n'est
pas possible de simplement s'abstenir il
faut voter contre
au sein du parti socialiste il y a eu
des coupures qui c'est à dire se sont
aggravées avec jean pierre chevènement
qui appelait à voter non et une fraction
du parti socialiste qui était aussi sur
cette ligne sans eau tout à fait la voix
apprennent et aux engagés là dedans que
la discussion entre nous commence à
s'animer dans la gauche socialiste
pourquoi parce que la cgt prend position
contre et le parti communiste français
aussi et ça nous ébranler beau mais ça
vaut aussi pour la droite qui a été
foudroyé par cette histoire là
[Musique]
un autre opposant est un tournant le 5
mai 1992 philippe séguin du rpr doit
prononcer à l'assemblée nationale un
discours réquisitoire historique de 2h30
il s'apprête à plaider pour
l'inconstitutionnalité du traité de
maastricht et réclament un référendum
c'est la première fois que je
participais vraiment une campagne
politique la première de ma vie
c'est aussi la première fois que
contribuer à des discours politiques
c'est un discours qui ne pouvait pas
être un discours de 10 minutes ni d'une
demi heure
ni d'une heure enfin il fallait que ce
discours soit un un discours qu'ils
tiennent une amie deux heures voire plus
et ce discours s'est déroulée dans une
moment très particulier
je m'en souviendrai toute ma vie je
viens voir ses gains d'assembler le soir
ta télé était allumée comme le faisait
souvent et relisez son son discours
et il était 20h
lors du journal télévisé
vous allez voir la tribune en ce moment
de bastia où le stade furiani me dit
alain scemama il n'y a semble-t-il du un
problème
c'était le choix naturel
semble-t-il une partie de la tribune
s'est effondré à l'instant vielles sur
ces images qui nous arrive en direct que
va peut-être nous commenté thierry
rolland s'il est au téléphone nous
entende on vous entend thierry qu'est ce
qui s'est passé patrick c'est une partie
de la tribune provisoire qui avait été
dressé à l'occasion de cette demi finale
tout à fait exceptionnelle entre bastia
et et l'olympique de marseille
une chute de 20 mètres des centaines de
victimes bloquées dans l'enchevêtrement
des tubes d'acier
[Musique]
ce disque wade prononcé dans une
atmosphère à ces dramatiques et en
pleine nuit dans une ambiance
crépusculaire
8 catastrophe
à l'assemblée les têtes sont donc
ailleurs lorsque philippe séguin
s'empare du micro
parole
monsieur le président messieurs madame
le ministre mes chers collègues
l'europe qu'on nous propose n'est ni
libre ni juste ni efficace
elle enterre la conception de la
souveraineté nationale et les grands
principes issus de la révolution
2h30 été brillant mais c'était un
orateur de talent je ne partage
absolument pas ces analyses qui était
tout à fait excessif et caricatural mon
frère il a pesé c'est beaucoup plus
qu'un moment charnière dans la campagne
c'est le moment qui a fait la campagne
sans le discours de philippe séguin il
n'y a pas de référendum voilà
trente-cinq ans que toute une oligarchie
d'experts de juges de fonctionnaires de
gouvernants prend au nom des peuples
sans en avoir reçu mandat des décisions
dont une formidable conspiration du
silence
dissimule les enjeux et minimise les
conséquences
et puis il commence à parler et puis
presque trois heures plus tard d'abord
l'hémicycle s'est remplie et tout le
monde comprend que est un vrai thème
politique dont il va falloir débattre
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
oui nous voulons l'europe mais de loin
parce que monsieur le ministre ces deux
bouts qu'on ait fait l'histoire
j'existe et j'ai été très frappée de
l'éloquence de philippe séguin de très
très bon discours je les félicite et ils
le méritent et d'ailleurs c'est un
discours républicain
et qui balayé large
j'étais bien ici
[Musique]
le lendemain même de ce discours le
président françois mitterrand se rend au
chevet des victimes de furiani est dans
l'avion le ramenant de corse se confie à
des journalistes de l afp et du journal
le monde il leur révèle en exigeant de
secret qu'il mettra en place un
référendum
françois mitterrand avait dit que s'il y
avait une majorité au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale
il ne recourrait pas au référendum et
puis
les sondages laissaient entendre que
le oui l'emporterait très largement et
donc du coup peut-être que françois
mitterrand reste les clans politiques
s'est dit ah ben si j'ai un succès dans
un référendum politiquement ça sur mieux
la deuxième partie du deuxième septennat
en quelque sorte et donc il s'est laissé
tenter
comment s'assurer que la légitimité et
complète est que le futur traité sans
que tu as he is et je pense que cette
question est présent dans l'esprit de
françois mitterrand avant même qu il
conclu donc je vais faire un référendum
françois mitterrand attend pourtant
plusieurs semaines avant de l'annoncer
aux français
après un événement très précis
surprise est aussi crise dans toute
l'europe les danois hier ont dit non au
traité de maastricht 22h30 hier soir au
folketing le parlement danois le
suspense est terminé premier pays
européen à voter premier pays à dire non
à 46 mille fois après la fête est finie
les fleurs aux couleurs européennes
peuvent regagner les serres alors que
chacun se demande qui paiera les pots
cassés
le nom des danois est arrivé comme un
coup de tonnerre c'est à dire je pense
que personne ne s'attendait à ce que le
danemark
[Musique]
vote de manière négative
peut-être naïvement beaucoup de
dirigeants politiques pensaient que
leurs opinions publiques allait être à
l'unisson l'opinion publique danoise
elle était certainement pas prête et ça
c'est vrai que c'est un choc en se
disant mais donc le référendum en france
même si tout le monde il sait très bien
tout d'un coup est ce que ça va être
aussi facile mitterrand à ce moment-là
et piqué au vif et chez lui le lendemain
qu'ils l'annoncent que la ratification
en france se fera par référendum
[Musique]
il y aura bientôt un référendum pour
ratifier le traité de maastricht une
fois acquise la révision
constitutionnelle c'est la décision de
françois mitterrand qui divise déjà la
classe politique mais la décision était
prise en main
ainsi convaincu aussi mitterrand
considéré à mon avis à juste titre que
pour un changement aussi capital passer
du paradigme france au paradigme europe
passer d'un système de référence à un
autre c'était un changement de monde on
ne pouvait pas ne pas consulter le
peuple français donc il l'a fait par an
référendum qu'il a décidé contre l'avis
profond de la plupart des dirigeants
socialistes qui considérait que c'était
un gros risque souvient que moi je
l'avais un tout petit peu mis en garde
pour ce changement de pied
[Musique]
à la table du conseil des ministres
c'est l'effarement qui se lit sur
plusieurs visages
j'avais dit à mitterrand
quand il a interrogé au conseil des
ministres tous ses ministres sur est ce
qu'il faut faire ratifier le traité de
maastricht par référendum j'ai été la
seule à dire oui faut le faire que
j'avais dit il des rampes plus continuer
comme ça à faire l'europe en inscrire
il faut démocratiser le processus sinon
ça finira par éclater et donc j'étais la
seule à dire ça tous les autres qui
étaient beaucoup plus expérimentés comme
quoi bien sûr voyez les risques d'un
référendum certains ont commencé à dire
dont pierre bérégovoy qui avait une
fibre qui n'était pas un militant
européiste ils étaient d'accord sur le
projet européen globalement mais il a
plus il avait des attaches populaire
réelle donc une sensibilité que n'avait
pas certains autres unis certains
instituts de sondage donc ils se disent
c'est quand même risqué
j'ai choisi comme vous savez le régional
c'est plus risqué
c'est vrai et je le sais ça quand même
normal de faire approuver par le peuple
français des décisions aussi importantes
qui les engage pour l'avenir parce que
quand même la monnaie unique c'est très
important personne ne s'y seraient
intéressés
or il faut que dans chaque village que
dans chaque commune que dans chaque
quartier dans chaque rue il y est une
formidable explications puisqu'il s'agit
est de la france et de l'europe
[Musique]
dès les jours qui suivent les clivages
politiques traditionnels explose les
partis politiques se déchire comme le
rpr le 4 juillet 1992 à la mutualité de
paris j'ai décidé de voter oui en toute
lucidité sans enthousiasme mais sans
états d'âme parce qu on chez lagardère
qu'il faut purement et simplement le
refuser et je peux pas interrompu
jacques chirac reste souriant mais la
salle lui répond non à maastricht ch
je crains que vous ne soyez déçu mais
j'ai un compagnon
et les sifflets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en garde un souvenir d'une belle
démonstration du courage en politique
chirac avec des convictions parce que
même si on a pu mettre en doute son
engagement européen il a toujours été un
européen de raison et comme ils
l'expliquent là il était essentiel pour
lui que nous progressions dans la
construction européenne or ce n'était
pas l'avis majoritaire du parti dont il
était le président et dont j'étais à
l'époque le secrétaire général parti
était divisé et je pourrais même dire
qu'une très forte majorité à la fois de
ses cadres de ces élus était favorable
au non je crois que c'était la moitié
des députés les deux tiers des sénateurs
beaucoup d'éminentes personnalités du
mouvement qui refuse l hôtel maastricht
et jacques chirac a tenu bon parce qu'il
s'agit de la france
ce furent des débats très très vif
puisque élus rp rien changé de
progressivement de position sous sous
l'effet de la pression qu'exerçait
edouard balladur et alain juppé ceux qui
les soutenaient il y avait les fractures
trêve il faut bien comprendre que
l'enjeu était énorme même si tout le
monde ne le ne mesurez pas donc à chirac
certains disaient ne sera jamais
président de la république si tu votes
non en se prononçant officiellement pour
maastricht jacques chirac a donc choisi
de préserver son image présidentielle
jacques chirac m'a confié j'ai été
sifflé hué par une partie du congrès qui
avait été ainsi organisés et il m'a dit
c'est sur lui que l'addition qui a été
la plus difficile à prendre mais c'est
parce que j'ai fait ce choix européen
c'est peut-être parce que aussi j'ai
pris mon propre parti de front pour
l'emmener vers une position qui était
celle de l'avenir que en définitive j'ai
gagné là les conditions pour devenir
président de la république
trois ans plus tard vous l'avez vu on a
vu dans des images ça a été évidemment
difficile mais c'était un moment où
l'autorité de jacques chirac était
contester un souvenez il avait perdu les
élections de 1988 donc cette
manifestation de la mutualité mais que
la traduction d'abord d'une divergence
de fond qui existe dans le mouvement
gaulliste depuis les origines et ensuite
d'un contexte politique de contestation
peu de l'autorité du chef mais voilà
pourquoi je dis un nom qui je le répète
est celui de la raison et de la
responsabilité oui à un traiteur oui je
veux dire un oui je veux dire
contre l'avis de son chef une partie du
rpr va sillonner la france pour
convaincre des dommages que provoquerait
le traité
j'avais interrompu les activités
professionnelles pour tornac delà de la
campagne et je me souviens très bien que
l'on était au milieu du foot france en
juillet et j'en étais sur la plage il
des chocs et la première surprise c'est
que d'emblée les salles étaient pleines
voulez vous qu on en cite des
fédérations multinationales et bâle 11 y
regardons ce qui s'est passé en union
soviétique
belle réussite
regardons ce qui s'est passé en
yougoslavie
belle réussite
c'est ça le modèle qu'on veut nous
imposer et bien si c'est ça nous devons
dire que nous n'en voulons pas séguin a
fait une campagne du feu de dieu si je
puis dire avec des affiches collées sur
les murs des villes s'étaient liberté je
chéris ton nom et daurelle naturellement
le slogan de la campagne du non était
quand même un des plus beaux slogans
qu'on ait jamais trouvé convoyer affiché
toute la france berthet jeu chaîne tombe
où
jean pasqua et rentrer en campagne à la
fin de l'été et c'est vrai que lui
victime devenait de plus en plus
importants et avec jean plus de chaleur
et de passion une gageure faire salle
comble en plein été pour une réunion
politique que l'exploit est signée des
partisans du non à maastricht à
carpentras hier soir devant 2000
personnes charles pasqua et philippe
seguin clôture et avant la trêve doubt
leur campagne du non au traité alors
dites-moi charles pasqua dans l'esprit
du public vous vous retrouvez quand même
dans une étrange coalision coalition à
côté de jean marie le pen de georges
marchais est à dire c'est une
association contre nature non vous avez
vu que nous avons pris soin de ne pas
organiser de cartel des normes je ne
suis ni aux côtés de jean marie le pen
ni aux côtés de genre de marché
non à mitterrand tel est le double mode
or le parti communiste est le seul parti
aujourd'hui où tous ses adhérents et
dirigeants appellent à voter non chacun
mène sa campagne et sur le plan des
objectifs généraux nous avons
certainement pas nous n'avons
certainement pas les mêmes
donc il n'ya pas d'étrangers coalition
de rassemblement pour le non au zénith
des défenseurs de la france a
curieusement choisi d'évoquer une
convention américaine
aucun ingrédient n'y manquent ni les
ballons neil orchestre ni les
accessoires bruyant pressaient les
sifflets ni les accoutrements militants
ni bien sûr une salle surchauffée 6000
opposants au traité pour applaudir son
ticket gagnant les trois mousquetaires
du nom qui s'auto intitule l'opposition
tout comme ses aînés ils ont voulu
ensemble pour le symbole parce qu'à une
semaine du référendum il croit que les
petites rivières peuvent faire le grand
fleuve du nom on pouvait compter sur
nous sur ce gain juan de viviez juan de
tous et sur moi même
pour ne pas baisser la garde
rien ne sera comme avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la panique s'empare de l'exécutif
dans sa traditionnelle interview
télévisée du 14 juillet le chef de
l'état donne lui aussi un tour tragique
aux enjeux du référendum
est ce que ce serait monsieur le
président un drame pour la france et
pour l'europe si le non l'emportait
ce serait un événement redoutable et
rapidement il s'est rendu compte que
dans la réalité qu'on les français
étaient confrontés à ce choix il
devenait beaucoup plus réticents mais
beaucoup de gens qui pensent que dire
non c'est simplement revenir à la
situation antérieure non ce serait
casser l'europe ça serait pas le moindre
doute il répudie là ce serait fini on y
croirait plus s'il
on en croit le président de la
république c'est apocalypse non
effectivement dit que nous risquions de
casser l'europe mais je crois très
sincèrement que je ne risque pas d'être
inculpés ou pré inculpé au titre de la
loi anti casseurs à l'elysée un homme en
particulier san lameer le conseiller
image du président jacques pilhan
jacques pile en était un des
spécialistes des grands experts de
l'opinion que la présidence de la
république mais d'autres membres du
gouvernement consulter régulièrement et
au mois de juillet si je me trompe pas
jacques pilhan vient me voir ils me
disent c'est préoccupant parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il ya un décrochage dans
l'opinion vous avez des gens qui vivent
la lavande et pas pendant pensée
embarqué ça va être extrêmement dur et
c'est vrai que la montée du nom finit
par devenir un facteur est bien
évidemment tout le reste de l'europe
nous regarde jeudi à mitterrand vous
savez dans les réunions qu'ils faisaient
là avec le che principaux miné et je dis
il faut faire campagne je vois aller sur
le terrain leur but avant de dire avec
un petit sourire narquois vous voulez
aller à trifouillis les oies louis
justement à trifouillis les oies et
je suis parti alors il y avait une grève
des camionneurs à l'époque avec un
personnage très haut en couleur tout à
trouver tout ça qui s'appelle argent
et alors et bloqué les routes durant une
semaine le pays est quasiment paralysée
motif le permis à points
c'est comme assez sérieuse alors des
préfets me disent de ne pas venir je dis
moi après 14 juillet je viens je suis
allé là et sur les plages dans les
campings ont été les jambes entre
siestes et baignade ce n'est rien moins
qu'un ministre qui vient porter la bonne
parole européenne dans les allées de ce
camping à tarascon-sur-ariège devant des
vacanciers surpris et souvent perplexes
de traiter que j'ai négocié quand même
écouter j'étais la seule à faire
campagne pour cet été là le miz affaires
étrangères roland dumas se faisait
photographier dans sa chaise longue chez
nous et là je pensais qu'il faut il
fallait c'était tellement sérieux qu'il
fallait rassembler toutes les forces qui
étaient courts
cette vision d'elisabeth guigou et de
valéry giscard d'estaing côte à côte
hier soir à sélestat on a irrité plus
d'un et pas seulement ou rpr au parti
socialiste il en est que les meetings au
coude à coude avec des leaders de la
droite insupporte alors ça ça fait
couler beaucoup d'encre c'était assez
compréhensible qu'il soit ensemble sauf
que c'est introduisez l'idée qu'il y
avait finalement une espèce de
combinaison de coalition entre la gauche
et la droite pour faire passer ce traité
ce qui faisait que une partie des
électeurs pouvaient être un peu
déboussolés donc chaque fois qu'il ya
effectivement l'idée que la gauche et la
droite peuvent se rapprocher sur une
question européenne eh bien il ya des
opposants qui dit vous voyez il y a une
forme de trahison
cela je vous arrête tout de suite je
suis pas venu pour parler de la
politique aux politiciens
vous parlez de ce traité de maastricht
a comme l'abbé pierre
dick comme patrick bruel des comme alain
delon gérard depardieu n comme les nobel
pierre gilles de gennes ou françois
jacob l'inventaire alphabétique des
partisans du oui s'allonger se dote de
stars en tous genres première salve de
la mobilisation des pros maastricht pour
contrer la montée du nom simone veil
pour l'opposition appelle les
pro-européens a levé on leur étendard on
a tout entendu à cette époque là c'était
europe c'est la paix s'il faut voter non
à ces voté non à l'europe donc faites ce
que vous voulez c'est en finir avec la
l'argument pas beaucoup changé
depuis vous ne pensez pas que ceux qui
ont fait campagne pour le non on peut
simplifier le débat aussi en disant
l'euro c'est la catastrophe c'est la fin
de la france c'est la fin de l'auto de
big de la souveraineté etc de l'identité
de la france et donc il faut rejeter
leurs eaux bon nous avons été conduits à
vendre des arguments aussi peu fort
enfin quand même faire des mobilisations
d'artistes sur un billet de banque c'est
difficile on a vu qu'il fallait
argumenté parce que la politique c'est
d'abord au delà des passions des
émotions
c'est d'abord des raisonnements et on
constate à ce moment là que les
arguments classiques pro-européen un peu
sympa un peu fun mais en même temps un
peu bisounours l'europe c'est la paix
l'avenir la jeunesse est tous ceux qui
sont pas cours ce sont des crétins
archaïque souverainiste arrête c'est à
toi on va que ça marche plus du tout
aucun des fêtes
y compris le fed avait lancé des ballons
et sur les plages de trucs ça ne porte
pas du tout donc il fallait changer de
campagne j'ai l'impression qu'il est un
membre un moment où ça commence à
flotter en avoir discuté et védrine je
me souviens dans leurs disputes
elisabeth guigou à ce qui était plutôt à
la manoeuvre qui était plutôt dans le
ressenti du pays il y avait une
inquiétude on arrive à une formule
août que feront ceux mi temps on va
utiliser dans le fameux débat une europe
forte vous protégera mieux
je crois que c'est la première fois que
la notion de protection entre alors
c'était pas du tout du tout le discours
de la gauche rallié à l'europe même
militante de l'anc
[Musique]
en août des premiers sondages donnent le
nom gagnant la fin du second septennat
approche l'échec n'est pas permis le
président d'entrer en scène
je sens que ça va mal si vous voyez dans
mon courrier joyeuse et des meetings
juin
le 14 août je prenais trois jours de
vacances chez moi dans le vaucluse on
m'appelle de l'édition le président veut
vous parler et me demande comment je
vois les choses vu du côté monsieur le
président préval si ça continue comme ça
on va perdre me dis venez me voir
danielle mitterrand m'accueille
françois saugier beaucoup
mais néanmoins nous avons une réunion
dans son bureau et je dis voilà il faut
que vous vous impliquer personnellement
sinon on va perdre et j'ai souvenir
aussi parce qu'on peut pas l'oublier de
la façon dont françois mitterrand malade
très malade
s'engage avec passion pour convaincre il
a vraiment pris en main la campagne se
souvient peut-être du débat qu'il ya eu
avec philippe séguin à la télévision
françois mitterrand décide surtout
d'organiser un show télévisé dans le
grand amphithéâtre de la sorbonne
l'émission et l'engagement du président
ont un impact décisif
[Musique]
juste avant l'émission et m'a fait venir
dans la loge de maquillage oui malibu
alors comment vous réagiriez touche à
écouter les plus forts quoi alors haïm
guichard
l'union fait la force
voilà l'union fait la force
le président fait notamment face à
l'écrivain jean d'ormesson si vous allez
aussi comme vous le demande non pas
seulement les adversaires mais je crois
bien des amis qu'en cas de victoire du
non
je veux dire non qu'en cas de victoire
du oui
c'est le lapsus 1 hormis celles en
kabylie encore jouable nous en parlons
j'ai parfaitement compris ce que veut
dire excusez pas de victoire on me
demande de partir en rade au riz en cas
de non
[Rires]
mais le duel historique annoncée
l'oppose à philippe séguin
j'ai eu la même impression tout le monde
c'est à dire que mitterrand l'avait un
peu baladé
séguin voulu être assez respectueux il a
voulu éviter l'affrontement brutal
l'homme qui était président de la
république et lui qui était simple
parlementaire donc ça permet à
mitterrand de faire usage de son esprit
caustique qui était une de ses grandes
armes là donc c'est ça n'a pas été un
élément décisif en faveur des tests de
philippe séguin quant au traité lui même
vous l'avez sous les yeux c'est une
bonne précaution mais moi je connais
assez bien pas besoin de l'avoir je ne
vais pas me gausse il se présente pour
vous dire que c'est quand même fou et
vous nommez si c'est un avantage
indéniable que j'ai eus qui me permet
d'avoir une connaissance et plus ancien
est peut-être plus profondes
je me souviens très bien pour y avoir
assisté c'est donc quand on fit théâtre
de la sorbonne
avec un 1 philippe séguin très
respectueux des institutions
et de la fonction présidentielle
et il avait en face de lui un mitterrand
très bas on est très rusé voir voir
autant mais surtout malade la veille au
soir à l'elysée il est venu dans mon
bureau
et il ne dit que voilà il va se faire
opérer après après l'émission le grand
public ne le sait pas encore et ne
l'apprendra que quatre jours avant le
scrutin françois mitterrand souffre d'un
cancer de la prostate
et ce soir là philippe séguin découvre
un président plus mal contraint de
recevoir des soins en coulisses
et quand on connaît ce gars est pour le
coup très c'est bien ce gars c'est un
affectif absolue c'était un tendre il
parle à françois mitterrand de façon
aimable presse de façon protectrice je
pense qu'il est choqué psychologiquement
et humainement par la maladie de
françois mitterrand est ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il s'est fait copieusement
engueulé par la suite par les autres
leaders de droite qui ont considéré
qu'il avait été trop gentil avec
françois mitterrand qui ne l'avaient
bref pas taper ou mis à mort
j'ai trouvé qu'il aurait pu pousser plus
loin son avantage en face de france
comme il y en qui il est vrai était
malade mais en plus tu excelles
politique
il faut défendre cette idée même si
quelquefois on est amené à aller contre
ce sentiment intime
philippe séguin était inspirée par une
certaine compassion à l'égard de
françois mitterrand pour avoir vécu
l'ambiance de cette de ce moment là
ce qu'il a fait était font très digne je
ne crois pas du tout comme l'on dit
certain que le fait que que c'est un
héros du ccoo
conduit à la victoire du oui la figure
de françois mitterrand qui était en fin
de mandat s'imposer c'était lui qui
comme chef de l'état alors qu'ils
n'avaient rien à gagner
pour lui-même donnait finalement une
perspective c'était son dernier souffle
on peut pas sous-estimer l'élément
affectif car présenté sa maladie et son
opération peu de temps
avant le vote ce qui d'exprimer était
une conviction tellement forte qu'elle
qu'elle passait je crois qu'il a été
déterminant de cette émission elle a eu
un impact parce que elle avait une
dimension pédagogique
formidable parce que ce gain a été d'une
grande élégance tout en défendant ses
convictions et parce qu'il y avait aussi
une dimension
humaine un peu pathétique c'est à ce
moment là
[Musique]
finalement le 20 septembre 1992
le oui l'emporté de justesse
des hommes politiques assez nerveux tout
au long de cette campagne les derniers
jours et je crois que cette nervosité
traduit une certaine incertitude sur le
résultat de ce scrutin la france dirait
oui à l'europe et elle ne dirait de
quelle manière
51% 51% des français dirais donc oui à
l'europe je dis bien dire et parce qu'il
faut être très prudent simone veil
vous sursautez lui est ravi ce soit et
où j'avais moi je me méfie tout de même
des sondages
à 8 heures pile et je n'ose pas encore
me réjouir c'est pas qu'il faut être
très très prudent 51 0 4% donc c'est
vraiment ric rac j'avais dit au début de
la campagne électorale
qu'il y aurait à l'issue de ce scrutin
ni vainqueur ni vaincu
le vote du sud jour engage toute la
france beh je respecte le sentiment des
libres citoyens qui en veux tu en eau
ont voulu sauvegarder des valeurs dans
lesquelles ils croient
imaginez maintenant
la joie des pays de la communauté
nos amis les plus proches
qu'ils attendaient de nous le seuil dont
il avait besoin
lorsque le résultat a été connu il ya eu
même une forme de surprise tellement
crié au dernier instant que ce soit le
nom qui finissent par l'emporter
et donc il ya eu une forme de fierté de
se dire que le combat avait été emportée
gagner alors même que
les conditions n'étaient pas forcément
réunies puisque à l'époque françois
mitterrand était très impopulaire quand
on en dise cette campagne elle a fait
passer le nom de des abîmes des sondages
a
presque une victoire c'est ric rac
donc
il ya un malaise dans le pays comme on
peut décider un truc aussi important
avec une marge si faible et le doute
parce que si vous voulez le doute qui a
commencé c'est dans l'évent d'ouïe la
preuve des gens comme moi il y aura qu
est-ce qu on est en train de faire
comment chercher toutes les
circonscriptions ouvrière du pays votre
compte rebonds c'est là le signal d'
alerte suprême par conséquent on a vu
apparaître pour la première fois ce
clivage entre les gagnants et les
perdants de la mondialisation
on a l'impression qu'à l'époque il ya
une france des
bien dotées ou bien pourvus qui a déjà
le début de la france intègre est
incluse ceux qui n'ont pas peur de
l'avenir et ceux qui sont déjà dans une
peur de leur propre déclin du déclin du
pays et qui n'ont pas confiance dans
leurs dirigeants
une france à deux vitesses prémices des
débats de la campagne présidentielle de
1995 autour de la fracture sociale
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont compris
que ça l'est seraient les premières
victimes c'est le début d'une révolte
qui va qui vont pas cesser de monter
dans une société qui se qui se
fracturent ça veut dire quelque chose ça
veut dire que les gens ont compris très
vite en quoi c'était un point de
basculement pour l'économie française
pour tout y soit notre pays la france
abandonné sa souveraineté monétaire
transféré dimanche compétences à la
banque centrale européenne et tout cela
ne peut pas manquer d'avoir un immense
conséquences sur l'accélération de la
désindustrialisation
de la france mais moi je ne crois pas à
ça je crois je crois que je sais bien
que c'est le souci principal de jean
pierre chevènement et je comprends ça
parce que à ce que c'est un drame
d'armes humain et je pense que si on
avait passé l'europe ça aurait été pire
encore est au fond le drame maastrichien
il commet 183 pourquoi parce que en 83
on découvre qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
le socialisme dans un seul pays et que
toute déformation de l'économie
française ce père est en déficit et du
commerce extérieur alors là c'est là que
françois mitterrand apparaît comme un
stratège parce qu'il puisse qu'on n'y
arrive plus dans le cadre national on va
y arriver dans le cadre international et
c'est pourquoi il faut renforcer
l'intégration européenne la france de
serena avait déjà décroché hélas
économiquement industriellement donc
monétairement par rapport à l'allemagne
donc pour la france si on résume un il
vaut mieux être quelque chose dans la
monnaie unique que d'être simplement
demandeurs et quémandeurs dans la zone
de marque c'est ça l'idée générale du
traité de maastricht
ça s'est joué à très peu de choses et si
vous faites la suite de l'histoire vous
voyez qu'en 2005 et bien c'est 55 % des
français se prononcent contre le projet
de traité constitutionnel
et puis si vous voulez consulter
aujourd'hui à partir d'une question dont
biaisé il est probable qu'il se
prononcerait contre l'europe telle
qu'elle fonctionne et contre laquelle
ils ont des critiques argumentées solide
qui tienne la route mais jean-pierre à
l'époque ne pas être pour cette europe
là c'est être contre l'europe alors le
nom du prénom mais on n'est pas contre
l'europe on est contre la façon de faire
l'europe c'est de la plaisanterie ce à
un moment donné si on franchit pas un
pas sur lequel on s'est mis d'accord
dans une négociation difficile dans un
traité si l'on dit non c'est fini
[Musique]
deux premiers ministres français assume
successivement la charge de la création
de l'euro mais pour être qualifié la
france doit d'abord respecter les
critères de maastricht ch
c'était pas anormal que pour faire
converger des monnaies nationales qui
allait disparaître vers une monnaie
unique qu'on fixe des critères de
convergence il fallait faire passer le
déficit public des différents états en
dessous de 3% et il fallait que la dette
publique des différents états ne soient
pas au-dessus de 60% du pib quand
j'arrive à matignon en 95 la date est
fixée au 1er janvier 99 l'euro vantera
d'applications pour les opérations
bancaires un peu plus tard pour les
billets les pièces il faut être au
rendez vous et quand j'arrive en 95 on
dépend d'où le déficit public de l'ordre
de 6% la norme à respecter ces 3 c'est
un effort gigantesque essaim pas mal
contribué à la popularité des mesures
que j'ai été amené à prendre pour
rétablir les équilibres budgétaires donc
le choix de maastricht c'était êtes vous
pour accepter la rigueur pendant 15 ans
1 pour obtenir ce fameux graal de la
monnaie unique c'était quand même un
raisonnement blizzard nous venons
d'arriver aux responsabilités en juin et
ça fait débat au début parce que
certains à l'intérieur de la majorité
voit les conditions comme des
et condition absolue comme des fecteau à
vrai dire mais nous ne voulions pas
d'une politique d'austérité nous
n'avions pas été élu pour ça ma majorité
de gauche et des écologistes n'aurait
pas accepté une telle politique et donc
nous demandons le gouvernement d'avoir
un peu de temps nous ne voulons pas
qu'on nous impose les critères de
maastricht et notamment la baisse du
déficit trop vite et nous allons plaider
dans ce sens la commission nous aidera
la commission européenne et puis
l'allemagne aussi comprendra et nous
suivra certes on respecte on est passé
sous les 3% du déficit public sous les
60% de la dette mais ça ne nous empêche
pas de mener une politique d'expansion
avec deux millions d'emplois créés et le
chômage qui baisse notre commerce
extérieur qui devient excédentaires donc
l'euro démontre que pour nous il n'est
pas un obstacle ou un carcan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi les premiers à donner l'exemple ce
matin le premier ministre col roulé et
poches pleines à dépenser sans compter
dans cet établissement comme dans
beaucoup d'autres ce 1er janvier on
annonce encore le prix en france
lionel jospin lui a compris la somme en
aura sept
léger flottement dans la boulangerie
vous vous rendez 20 centimes d'euro
le peintre bien 7 francs et non 7 euros
la nouvelle monnaie est encore à
apprivoiser bien sûr ça peut désarçonner
certains il y aura un moment
d'adaptation
[Musique]
en dehors d'une dimension qui a existé
quand même critique qui était que se
réfère à accroître les prix monter les
prix ce que les statistiques démontrent
pas tout à fait finalement
l'accueil a été bon nous avons gagné
l'euro a réussi est aujourd'hui une très
forte majorité d'européens dans les
états membres de la zone euro et en
france considèrent que l'euro les a
protégés tout au long des crises qui se
sont succédé donc lhi dray a triomphé et
aujourd'hui plus personne de sérieux ne
considère qu'il faut sortir de la zone
euro mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'adhésion à l'europe soit
massive il ya toujours des critiques qui
se font à l'égard de l'europe et
notamment par rapport aux fameux
critères de maastricht on retient de
maastricht aujourd'hui non pas tant la
création de l'euro que les critères qui
justifierait ou qui ont justifié des
politiques de rigueur budgétaire
bien sûr il est une monnaie unique mais
n'a mis la charrue avant les boeufs on a
mis la monnaie avant la politique on
n'est pas d'accord sur les grands choix
politiques en matière non seulement
économique et social mais aussi en
matière de politique étrangère la
défense donc voilà c'est un un curieux
attelage où chacun tire dans la
direction qu'il croit juste
mais où on n'a pas encore
défini une orientation politique commune
et je doute que ce soit possible mais
l'avenir est ouvert
encore aujourd'hui maastricht a un
impact sur la vie des français et des
européens
trente ans après l'union européenne
continue de diviser les classes
politiques elle suscite l'engouement ou
le rejet
trente ans après l'union européenne n'a
pas fini de déchaîner les passions
[Musique]
pas
le
[Musique]